- Hello, and thanks so much for joining
for this brief presentation
on our experiences with
the EPI LAMP program.
And specifically, how we
have adapted leadership
and management training for
national immunization teams
in the context of COVID-19.
My name is Erika Linnander,
I direct a group out of Yale
called the Global Health
Leadership Initiative
and I'm joined in this
experience by my colleagues
in our partner organizations
as part of the EPI LAMP consortium,
including representatives
from the University of Global
Health Equity in Rwanda,
the University of Yaounde
in Cameroon, GAVI, PATH,
and of course, our students
and alumni in the program.
So the reason that I wanna talk with you,
about the EPI LAMP experience
and our adaptations in
the context of COVID,
is that we know that
leadership and management
are essential in the COVID response.
So in times of crisis,
we really need national immunization teams
to be able to come
together, solve problems
and move forward in a
coordinated national response.
And yet at the same
time, we see investments
in routine health system
strengthening being diverted
into more acute COVID response.
And, our old models of
training for leadership
and management just aren't
viable in the context
of COVID given restrictions
on travel and convening.
And so the question becomes,
how can we provide support for leadership
and management in this new context?
So just to provide a little bit background
on what the EPI LAMP program is,
EPI LAMP is a nine month
certificate program
for natural immunization teams
in GAVI eligible countries.
So we have participants come together
as teams to build their
management and leadership capacity
in the six areas shown
on the poster there,
strategic problem solving,
leading effective teams,
political engagement,
human resource management,
financial management, and
supply chain management.
We've been delivering
the program since 2018.
We're now offering the program
for cohorts four and five.
So we've reached 54 alumni
and 49 current delegates
across 27 GAVI eligible countries
in French and English
speaking, Africa and Asia.
Obviously like most of us we were forced
to adapt the program in
the context of COVID 19,
and I wanna tell you a little bit
about how we've done that
and our results to date.
So if you zip over to the
right-hand side of the poster,
you see, we used two
methods for adaptation.
The first thing we did,
is we worked with each
participating country
to undergo a structured risk assessment
to understand how were
they working remotely.
Were they working remotely?
How was it going?
Any lessons learned there?
What was their internet
connectivity and cost like?
Would they be able to
participate in the program,
given competing priorities?
So what would the program have
to look like to be on demand
and flexible and how might
they like to collaborate?
We combined that
country-specific risk assessment
with a review of the literature,
the peer reviewed literature
and the gray literature
around best practices
for online education for professionals.
And as a result of those two inputs,
the country specific assessment
and then the kind of systematic
review of best practices,
we came up with five adaptations
to the EPI LAMP experience
that I wanna talk with you about.
The first thing that we came up with,
with a framework,
we came up with a way of
approaching in the creation
of a professional learning community,
that was evidence-based.
So we could have confidence,
and our participants could have confidence
that we were attending to
all the different parts
of curricular approaches
that would be needed
for them to be successful.
We also shifted away
from in-person convenings
and instead moved to increase investment
in some small group facilitation online,
meaning a lots of breakout rooms,
investment in facilitators
in those breakout rooms,
they could use Miro and
other knowledge capture tools
to make sure that these sessions
were really active and engaging.
We updated the curriculum with
COVID specific applications.
So, still teaching the real essentials
of management and leadership,
then making sure that
they were always focused
on the practical challenges
that teams were facing
in the context of the COVID response.
We broadened our communication
channels to include Slack
and WhatsApp so that we're
able to reach delegates,
to reach participants on multiple channels
throughout the day, throughout the week,
throughout the program.
And finally, we found mechanisms
to get participants
cash for mobile access.
So across our participating countries,
we found that actually
the internet was okay,
it was just expensive.
And so we needed, if we wanted
participants to come online,
turn on their videos,
participate actively,
we needed to make sure
that they had the financial compensation
to buy that airtime and
turn their videos on.
We're just over halfway
through the program now,
through cohorts four and
five with this new model.
And I wanna share a little
bit about results to date.
First of all, as you see
in that middle panel there,
we're having 88 participation
in our bi-weekly live sessions.
That means that despite
their busy schedules,
despite the challenges
of internet connectivity,
participants are coming
online and participating.
We think this is because the sessions
are highly interactive,
because the content is relevant
and because they're learning
from each other in those sessions.
We've also seen that
the demand for coaching,
we provide coaching to
each one of the teams
and the demand for
those coaching sessions,
is twice what it has been in past cohorts.
So again, even though these
participants are very busy
in the context of COVID,
we're seeing that they
actually want more coaching,
again, highlighting the
relevance of the program.
And because of this new model where things
are better integrated,
and we're being much more responsive,
we're seeing better progress
on their breakthrough projects
now halfway through the program
compared to prior cohorts.
So this integrated virtual model
of delivery is actually
delivering better results
than the old model of
bringing participants together
for periodic in-person trainings.
So what does this mean?
What do we take from this experience?
First of all, national
immunization professionals
are demanding leadership support
despite the competing challenges
associated with COVID-19.
So we thought they'd be too busy.
We thought they'd be distracted,
but instead they're telling us,
no, we need leadership support now,
do not cancel this thing.
The second implication
that we're seeing is that
through systematic adaptation
using the methods that
I've described earlier,
virtual models can be accessible,
engaging, and responsive.
So the virtual stuff can work
as long as you go about it systematically
and based on evidence.
And lastly, I think we're seeing
from our participants, a call
for leadership development
to remain part and integral part
of national and global
response and recovery.
Thanks for taking the time to listen
and learn a little bit more
about the EPI LAMP program.
If you wanna learn even more,
scan the QR code up in
the top left corner,
that will take you to our website.
That'll give you a little
bit more background
on the program as well as
some mobile friendly content.
So you don't have to squint
at this tiny little PDF poster.
Thanks again.